>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Mary Quattlebaum: Hello,
well I like a response.
A big welcome to the
National Book Festival.
My name is Mary Quattlebaum and I
review middle grade and teen fiction
for the Washington Post and the
Post is then a charter sponsor
of this fine Festival since
it began sixteen years ago.
I'm going to ask you to join me
in thanking a few folks before we
introduce our wonderful author.
First, the Library of Congress
who's been the festival's host
since the beginning.
A big thank you to Festival
co-chair, David Rubenstein,
and other festival sponsors.
We've got to give a big round
of applause to our volunteers
and we know them this year by their
blue shirts, they come back year
after year and the festival
couldn't happen without them.
So thank you.
[ Audience Clapping ]
And on behalf of the festival,
I want to say a huge thank you
to you our audience of
book lovers, you know,
you guys we got a thank you
for caring deeply about books
and their creators for sharing
books with friends, kids, students
and even random strangers.
There's also a chance to donate,
you know, if you really want
to show your love and this will help
to keep the festival
going and growing.
You can check your program for
details, also, just to let you know,
there's going to be a chance
to ask questions after the talk
and also just to let you know, there
are mics at either side of the room
and if you ask a question
you will be filmed
for the libraries archives.
So, our author I am
thrilled, capital T thrilled
to introduce Meg Medina today.
Through her books and in the
work she does for the community,
Meg is a powerful,
insightful, compassionate voice
for young people -
especially for girls.
Meg spoke movingly two years ago
at the National Book Festival
about her acclaimed novel, Yaqui
Delgado Wants to Kick Your Ass,
and I was here with my husband
and my teenage daughter,
there wasn't a dry eye in the
house and there were a lot of eyes.
So, there were a lot of tears
and a lot of connection with Meg.
Meg writes across a range of
ages from picture books to novels
for young adults, the Review Journal
Booklist calls her writing heartfelt
and truthful.
Her first book the picture
book, Tia Isa Wants a Car
when the Ezra Jack
Keats New Writers' medal
and the awards just keep coming.
Her latest novel, Burn Baby
Burn, was recently included
on the long list for the National
Book Award that is a huge honor
for an important sensitive
work of historical fiction.
And I also have to tell you, you
know, we all know Meg's book,
In The Disco Ball is on the cover,
a Sunday At The Gala Last Night
and she was rocking some
enormous shiny disco ball earrings
which unfortunately
she did not wear today.
When she isn't writing, Meg is
busy with community projects
that support girls,
Latino youth and literacy.
These projects all speak deeply
to her Cuban-American roots.
So, please join me in welcoming
the amazing Meg Medina.
[ Audience Clapping ]
>> [Inaudible] cross
and see a friend.
>> Meg Madina: Hi everybody.
Hola, que tal?
I'm so excited to be here again
at the National book Festival
and yes it's true that I was wearing
disco ball earrings last night
and Rocking them at the
Library of Congress.
So it was all an honor of
course, Burn Baby Burn.
So how long does it
take to write a book?
And that's the question that
I get asked all the time,
it's usually asked me by a
writer who's like dog-tired
of the project they're
working on their sick of it
or sometimes it's asked by a
kid who's trying to do the math
like how long do I want to put
in to, you know, write this book
that somebody is going to
read in an hour or a day.
So how long did it take me
to write Burn Baby Burn?
And I'm going to tell you that
it took me forty years and that's
because sometimes long before a
book is made up of words it's made
up of emotions and
scraps of memories
that keep tangling in your feet.
So, Burn Baby Burn is
set in Queens in 1977
and it follows the tumultuous
life of Noda Lopez who's a teen
that awful year and she's trying
to figure out what comes up next
in her life besides getting
away from her crazy family.
But he's a thing that was historical
fiction which is a sobering fact
to accept, not only because
1977 kind of feels too close
to be called history, but mostly
because I'm not a historian
and so I was thinking "what
business do I have taken
on historical fiction?"
But regardless of what I was
thinking about consciously,
regardless of what I was telling
myself that I could or couldn't do
as a writer, the story of that girl,
of that family, of that horrible,
horrible year in New York's
history was already in the works.
Here are the facts; I was a
brand-new teenager in 1977.
I lived in Flushing with
my mother and my sister.
My mother was a Cuban immigrant
who didn't speak English well,
who was a divorced mom
raising two teenage girls
at the height of disco and drugs.
She lived in a city that
was on the brink of a motion
of economic and social collapse.
My mother lived a lot of her
life in a cloud of anxiety.
When I think of her
today, I always think
of her saying, Cuidado be careful.
My sister, five years
older, was an art student
at the high school
of Art and Design.
She was also a budding radical
feminist, a loner, an intellectual,
a girl wrestling with her own
identity and with her rage.
Together, we were girls that my
poor mother didn't understand.
We were girls trying to figure out
who we were at a time when women all
around us were demanding
new opportunities of ways,
a new way of being thought of.
So, this is how a book begins.
It doesn't start with me saying
I think I'll write a historical
fiction about New York City,
instead it starts with memories.
The big portable record player that
opens like a suitcase left behind
by my father when he left us.
The way I dropped the
needle on the LP and listen
to Donna Summer groaning,
Love To Love You Baby
and my mother saying,
Qué dice la mujer?
What's that woman saying?
My sisters shrieking with laughter
because I didn't know, not really,
I just danced, a memory of Ms.
magazine and my sister and I pouring
over the no comments section
which consisted of examples
of sexist ads all around us.
How I stared one day for such a
long time at an ad for Bowling Lanes
that said Beat your Wife Tonight.
A memory of working so hard to get
that stupid Farrah Fawcett hair flip
and my very cool marshmallow
wedge shoes;
a memory of the loud
arguments that erupted
in our apartment and
made me ashamed.
The smell of urine in the subway,
the pop of the spalding pink balls
against the schoolyard walls,
the catcalls, oh yeah, mommy.
Kids hanging outside the building
on the dirty hoods of cars
in the summer and of
course there was the fear -
what if mom lost her job?
What was up with all those
fires being set in the Bronx
and what about son of Sam?
So, 2016 marks the 40th anniversary,
the beginning of David Berkowitz's
reign of terror in New York as son
of Sam, a killer with a forty
four caliber revolver and a thirst
for young women with brown hair.
He began shooting girls that summer,
two young girls back from a night
out who were sitting in
a parked car talking.
It wouldn't be until March that
the police confessed finally
that we had a serial
killer on our hands
but by then he'd been writing
letters to the city and to police
by mailing them to the Daily News
which published them in part.
They were chilling and
poetic rambling note
about where he'd go next,
"I'll be back", he always wrote
and he made good on that promise.
In all he would murder
six and injure seven more.
Many of those murders unfolded in
my neighborhood and in my borough.
The police task force was
headquartered at the hundred
and ninth precinct in Main
Street Shopping District
where I walked every day.
One of his early shootings
was outside a bar
on Depot Road a few
blocks from where I lived
and of course there
were the shootings
at other nearby Queens' places
like Forest Hills and Bayside,
only a few bus stops away.
So, what I remember is
hanging on a parked car
with a girl named Jenny Lee talking
about who we thought the killer was.
She could be that guy at the
Deli or how about that weirdo
on the bus, may be even our super.
That July when New York finally had
a blackout during an epic heat wave,
I was home alone and son of
Sam was still on the loose.
My mother and sister had gone to get
cigarettes and my first thought was,
oh no, he's here to get me.
Memories that won't leave
you that tangle in your feet,
and so finally I had the
sense to decide to wrestle all
that disco music, all that fear, all
that chaos into the story of a girl.
Researching a book like this is hard
and exciting especially
when you're a newbie.
I worked right here
in DC at the Library
of Congress rediscovering the
questionable joys of microfiche
as I reread issues of Ms.
Magazine and the Daily News
and the New York Times articles
about all the cities troubles.
I tried to read everything in order
so that I could scare myself all
over again and it worked.
I had the chance to
interview also women
who considered themselves disco
queens about their favorite outfits,
their favorite dance
partner, the DJs they loved.
I interviewed a former police
officer who investigated son of Sam,
who confessed that they had
known far earlier than they let
on what the trouble really was.
I interviewed my friend, John, who
pumped gas in Queens that summer
and he recalls the
tow truck that brought
in a bullet riddled Cadillac
dusty with white fingerprint dust,
fresh from the scene of
the Ella Fish shooting.
Research about the blackout was
the most revealing actually for me,
people who are trapped in the
World Trade Center restaurant,
for instance, were treated
to champagne that night
as they looked at the
moonscape below.
If you lived in an upscale suburban
neighbourhood, you spent the night
on your stoop having a cookout with
your neighbors with all that food
that was spoiling in your
mother's refrigerator,
or maybe playing flash
type tag with your friends.
But if you lived in a
working-class neighborhood
or a poor neighbourhood, you
saw all hell break loose.
Stories you've known all your
life were alluded to the studs
by all kinds of people,
young and old, criminal
and formerly law-abiding.
New cars were driven straight
through the show room windows
and off into the street.
So many fires were set
in that 24-hour period
that the fire department stopped
responding, and in the end all
that the city had left with
accusations and finger-pointing
and a soul-searching
for what was happening
to us, what were we becoming.
And so I learned as an adult about
the backdrop of race and class
and urban decay that I didn't
really understand at 13
but I had somehow shaped
my life anyway.
For me, the very hardest
decision in research was
as to whether I should reach out
to the parents of the victims
of the son of Sam killings.
I chose not to in the end, instead
I researched newspaper accounts
and kept my mentions of the
young victims to a minimum.
I try my best to treat the violence
as a matter of historical record
and not as a way to sensationalize
the book or to use the death
of these beautiful young
people as entertainment.
My reasoning is that these families
suffered an enormous loss once.
Even today they miss these young
people that never got the chance
to grow up and I didn't
want to add to their pain.
So it somehow became a book about a
family struggling at the same time
when the city all around
them was struggling.
It's been so gratifying to me
to see this book well received.
I love it when I meet young people
who say "your book was really scary.
I couldn't read it by
myself" because it tells me
that I did a good job at re-creating
the dread that we all felt
as though something was
right over our shoulder.
It's felt good to me to hear
from New Yorkers who lived
through that time including
a librarian from Larchmont,
New York who told me she
remembers the day exactly that son
of Sam was arrested
in her neighbourhood,
in Yonkers where she lived.
She recognized him right
away as one of her neighbors.
I even feel gratified
when I hear people say
that disco music is now lodged
hopelessly in their brain for days.
You know Roger Sutton
at the hornbook humming Burn Baby
Burn is just too good for words.
So, in an unexpected twist
of fate something I couldn't
have imagined happened and that's
that the 1970s is suddenly
so much in the media now.
Does anybody here watch The Get
Down on Netflix that has taken over
and there were episodes of Vinyl,
polyester is back people
whether you wanted or not?
So I could ask myself why, why
the 70, why this look back?
But then I think as I often do of
my mother and I already know why.
"Todo se repite", everything
repeats itself she told me.
And so I look at teens today
in 2016 who live with the fear
of unexpected violence,
these school shooter drills,
the bomb sniffing dogs in our Metro,
the worry of whether
someone will open fire
at a mall, at a movie theatre.
I look at the racial struggles of
young African-Americans with police,
especially, this summer, this
week that has just passed.
I look at it all and it feels
so familiar in the sadness
and in the rage and
in the senselessness.
Forty years have passed,
1970s, 76, 77 to 2016, 2017;
it took me 40 years to write
this book and to make sense
of the violence of my early life.
So, I want to end here by asking
the teens and the early adults here
to pay attention to what is around
you, to what you are living now.
In forty years, what's
going to be the soundtrack
of this time and of your life?
What are the social issues and the
struggles that shape you every day?
What are the haircuts, the styles?
What are the random moments of
your daily life that they're going
to follow you forever
until you have to knit them
into a story of your own?
Your story will be the
story of 2016 but, you know,
it will also be the
story of young people
in all times because Todo se repite.
So what is it that you'll need
to say, that you're burn to say
about being young and new
in this world gone crazy.
Thank you.
[ Audience Clapping ]
So, I think.
Where is my time keeper?
Oh its perfect timing,
I never get to do that.
I did it right this
time I didn't over talk
which is a big problem for me.
I would love to answer
your questions,
I can even demonstrate
disco moves if I'm pressed.
So, you know, come forward.
I think there's two microphones
and don't leave me hanging people.
Yeah.
>> So why do you think despair makes
for such an interesting book topic?
>> Meg Medina: Despair because
when I think of being a teenager
that sadly, the feeling that
I associate with what it was
like to be young was despair.
Like it was fun; it
involved friends,
it involved joyeus things that,
you know, parents always tell you,
you should be grateful for.
For example, I'm sure you've
heard your parents say:
what are you complaining about?
This is the best time of
your life etcetera, etcetera.
And all the young people are
like, have you lost your mind?
Because it's painful, because
there's no way to unfold as a person
without killing off some
parts, distancing ourselves
from people we love, duking
it out, loathing ourselves.
And so I think that is a connection
and I think most of the teens
in here those days when you
wake up and you're just mad.
You're just mad inside,
the world feels angry
and that's what I wanted to capture.
Thank you for that question.
Anybody else?
Come on. Alright am I really
going to have to do the hustle?
Okay, here comes Mary.
Hey.
>> Mary Quattlebaum: But you know,
I'm going to put you on the spot
and ask for the dance moves, no.
>> Meg Madina: okay
>> Mary Quattlebaum: I'm kidding.
>> Meg Madina: My former
friend, Mary, yes, yes.
>> Mary Quattlebaum: I was curious
about what you're working on now
and also, you know, you are
such a strong voice for
girls and for women.
You know, we're just living a
rape culture at this point in time
and I'm wondering if your next works
are going to explore some of that.
>> Meg Medina: Yes.
So yes I am a passionate advocate of
girls in literature for strong girls
and do a lot of work around that.
Not only in making sure that my
books feature strong girls and women
but my work in the
community has the girls
of summer reading list and so on.
So, the next book that
I'm working on,
I have two that will
come at a Candlewick.
One is a young adult novel that
features a brother and a sister
who end up going to
the same high school
for the first time in their lives.
One is a typical peer,
one is a young person
who has intellectual disabilities
and how they have to figure out,
how to share that space together.
That's not the one I'm working on
now because that one feels so hard
and there's so many tangled memories
that I still have to let that float
in the ether for a while.
So, what I'm doing right now is
working with a middle grade novel
about a girl named Mercy Suarez.
She lives in South Florida with
her entire extended budinski
Cuban family.
You can imagine the problems,
so that's what I'm working on.
Hi there.
>> What do you do in
your writer's block?
>> Meg Medina: That, you
know, what I really do.
I try to get up and move.
I take a walk, I garden, I do
something physical just sort of get
out of my brain for little while.
I love to read passionately, I read
every single day for long periods
of time and sometimes I just can't,
melting into somebody else's
story gives me ideas for my own.
And then sometime I just stop for
a while and walk away and work
on something else and come back to
it when I feel little less tired.
What you do when you
have writer's block?
>> Ah.
>> Yeah, you say, ah no.
Well, we all say that same
thing, well, try this.
Hey, how are you doing?
>> Good.
>> Who is your favorite writer?
>> Meg Medina: My favourite
writer, you know,
the person whose book I'm
reading at the moment,
it changes almost every day
but I will tell you Kwami
Alexander is a dear friend of mine
and I really do love his books.
I love Jason Reynolds
book, I mean there's just
so many different writers and I
also like different kinds of books.
Like some people really
just like one type of book
but I like realistic fiction
but I like also science fiction.
I like, you know, all kinds
of things, graphic novels.
What's your favorite kind of book?
>> I don't know.
>> Meg Medina: Yeah, so you know
I just like everybody, I guess.
Yes, on this side.
>> Hi, I just want to say thank
you for being, for making a space
for Hispanic writers and for being
such a strong Hispanic role model
for people who want to
write and like there is no
that many Hispanic writers right
now so I'll just say, thank you.
>> Meg Medina: Oh, my gosh.
That makes me feel wonderful
and thank you and I want
to tell you I want you to
follow Latinos in Kid Lit
because it's a wonderful blog of all
of the new Latino writers coming up.
And there's just so many
exciting voices producing work
and maybe yours will be
added in there as well.
I think there's been no better
time to be a Latino writer than now
because we do know each other.
We are making community and
we are also sort of working
as literary activists, there
is no other option, right?
When we have so few books that are
published by people of color, right?
So, we write our work and we send
it out into the world but then we're
in schools, we're working
with young people.
We're working with new
writers and we're trying
to be literary citizens really
Sue da danos [phonetic].
>> I also like how
you're being Hispanic
and you're creating Hispanic
characters and it's not normal
if we don't make the space, no
one is going to do it for us.
>> Meg Medina: Right.
>> So you're, you're really
taking a stance there, and...
>> Meg Medina: Thank you, thank you.
And I hope that I'm the
representations I make feel real
and authentic because that
matters beyond the piñata matters.
[ Audience Clapping ]
Can I take one here?
Yes.
>> So I have a book that I'm writing
and a character in it emerged
that is a young Hispanic girl
and I'm just wondering
what should I be careful
of as a non-Hispanic
writing this character?
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
>> So I don't want to, you
know, just do the piñatas.
>> Meg Medina: Yes,
well I have two minutes.
So that's a scary question.
So, here's what I would say.
It's very easy to get
it wrong and the way
that people typically get it
wrong is not in the big things,
it's in the small details
of people's lives.
Always write a person,
a person who is
of a culture not the
other way around,
a culture who is a
person in your book.
So, you need to be careful of that.
If you hang out after
work you and I can talk.
There's someone who just
did a pretty good blog post
on some things, but if I were you
the best advice I could give you is
to write the person, to vet the
book with people of that culture,
and to listen to their advice
when they say you got this
wrong or maybe consider that.
It'll just spare you
I think some pain.
Yes.
>> I'm the mother of a budding
young writer and I don't know
if you are physically writing
as a teenager but if you were,
did you have some kind of, you
know, daily practice, writing?
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
I was writing always but I
didn't have a daily practice,
I don't keep a journal, right?
Only in emergencies I
did, I keep a journal
for certain really key
moments but I don't.
I think the practice that I have
that has been with me since I was
in the third grade is
that I read voraciously.
I'm never not reading and it gives
you avenues into other ideas,
into other people's
lives, into vocabulary.
It's a comfort, it's an escape,
it's all the things you
guys know about books.
I cannot imagine my life
without story and books,
so if I had somebody who is a
budding writer I would give them a
whole room in your house man
that is filled with books.
You're welcome.
>> Did you know you
wanted to be a writer?
Did you know you wanted
to be a writer?
>> Meg Medina: Yes, I did but it
took me a long time to admit it
and the sign now says
wrap up please.
So I want to thank you
so much for coming out.
I want you to go disco dancing
in the near future and thanks
for coming out and enjoy
the rest of the festival.
Cariño.
[ Audience Clapping ]
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov